before we move on we have a cool product
to check out today it's the everyday
earbuds by raycon look at these
these are nice they don't stick out of
your ears like other brands they're
great raymond comes with a bunch of gel
tips so it feels comfortable they also
have a 32-hour battery life longer than
most earbuds i ever used music is
essential to me to drown out all the
music around me and keep me in the zone
i want to focus on being the baddest
[ __ ] on the planet drown
everything out look i feel good they
feel secure and affordable too only half
the price of the premium auto brands
also comes with a 45 day happiness
guarantee my listeners at home should
check them out i approve they can use
raicons to listen to this podcast and if
you want to buy your own pair of raycon
go to buy raycon.com
boxing to get 15 off your purchase
youtube viewers can click the link in
our description box below buy records
mike told you to oh this is good this is
what we're talking about yeah i don't
want to call her a tomato but
wow
if my mentor called you a tomato candy
that would be that's worse than calling
you a [ __ ] that's just some bad stuff
in boxing the way i grew up my trainer
he's from he born in 1908 there's
nothing worse than a tomato can to him
if he calls you a dominican he has no
respect for you your life your mother i
don't know why
i don't know what i don't know what the
freeze is because the tomato can won't
give it won't it won't poop you can't
push it you can blow it over it won't
resist nothing just [ __ ] can useless
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen i have the
opportunity to be blessed here
with the greatest fighter of her
generation
and she's um getting ready to supersede
that and be the greatest fighter in the
mma
and i'd like to introduce the world's
greatest violence clarissa shields
but i was watching if y'all didn't clap
on my clap everybody clap please
[Applause]
you're the boss
so tell me i see here you miss you've
been um boxing since you're 11 you start
at 11 what caused you to want to be a
boxer
you know what i really started boxing to
take after my dad my dad had been in
prison for a couple years
he got out when i was nine years old
and uh he just was telling me if he was
stuck to what he was passionate about he
would never went to prison and i was
like
what were you passionate about he said
boxing so i really took a boxing so my
dad
could live some of his life through me
so by doing this tell me tell me about
the first time you ever got in the ring
the first time i ever sparred i had been
training for two months
it was against one of my close friends
darion lawson i called him my cousin
and uh he had been boxing for five years
compared to my two months and he uh
just picked on me every day for the
first two months of training saying like
girls don't need to be in the gym you
don't know what to get yourself into i'm
gonna beat you up when we spar
and uh when we sparred my first time
sparring
i got hit in the nose and my eyes got
watery
and then that's when i found out that i
was a true savage because i kicked
darion's ass
watching this interview
listen i wanted to fight in the olympics
i lost in the trials but um i was a
alternate so i went to los angeles to
watch the olympics and so i went around
and then i met sugary robinson i met
some old friend i met him right i mean i
was like a real groupie he said you got
to be in shape you got to make sure
you're running and saying i ran 10 miles
that day
okay just because he told me i had to be
in shape he these guys had a big
influence on me
and
and that's and that's why i want to know
who had to put a big influence on you
beside your phone you have to see a
fighter say hey
i want to be like that
you know what
it was muhammad ali really that's the
fighter who i saw and i said
i want to be like him and not just him
inside the ring but like him all around
like i want to be as confident as him i
want to be here so pretty much you want
to be an activist yeah yeah
muhammad ali um when i was he's the most
confident fighter that ever lived
you know i studied him a lot and um most
of his fighting as he got a little old
absolute um psychology you know i'll
leave with boxes but you would never
think you know what if they hate them
i'll leave be in the clinch talking
about their mother screaming their
mother their sister would i caught your
sister around the truck and i fit this
and ali is the most disgusting person
when he's in the ring fighting he's man
he's saying things so bad the referee
said i just can't even tell you what he
was saying i never thought he would do
it
but he's talking about screwing this
person in your family and this and that
and joe frazier said what kind of man is
like that who does that you know and
that's just who he was he was a
psychology he fought like you know he
had to stay he got to a certain age but
he wasn't as fast as he was and so he
used a lot of psychology i think that
boxing had a lot to do with out to egos
because we're not who we are inside the
ring outside the ring
you can fight without the ego
that part
you can fight this is an interesting
thing
that um you can learn right now
we need the ego to fight we need the ego
to succeed we need the ego because the
ego is just protecting us they believe
but um
what happens um
you know when the ego is out of control
we all go to that part when they go out
of control we think we're more than what
we are the ego is only an illusion
that controls us in some states just an
illusion doesn't exist
but we make it exist and for making that
ego exist we accomplish really great
things
but it's only an illusion
in that one something that doesn't have
no existence can make something real
well ain't that what faith is though
faith is different
faith is different like faith is like
believing that something is possible
without actually seeing that it's
possible because that's i'm like i'm a
i'm a christian so i'm more faith-based
and it's like
if you're going to read jeremiah 29 11
and say i grew up poor and i didn't
really have nothing so this
this uh bible scripture here kept me
kept my ego and kept and kept my hope
alive growing up and say for i god know
the plans i have for you plans to give
you
um plans to give you a better future and
prosper and so even though i was going
through a lot i was hungry i didn't have
clothes i didn't have shoes i didn't
have a bed it was like for our god know
the plans i have for you plans to give
you a better future and plans you to
prosper so that's where my faith
came from and where i was like god got
something planned for me i just had to
stay accord and and how i made it was
through boxing you know i love and i am
my religion
but when you look at that bible you look
at that quran you look at it get the
bagita you look at these books and i say
even if they got a million pages can
that define god
no
okay i just could i get confused
sometime and that's why i'm
i used to know um religion is just
beautiful
and god is beautiful and everything god
made here is beautiful the murder is
fighting everything is from love
everything we do here from love i know i
don't understand even fighting this love
yeah it is everything is love knowing
that you i'm talking about real fighting
to the death knowing that you got my
back i got your back i got your back and
then that's love it's all love dying is
love you reach your highest purpose in
life when you you no longer exist then
you meet god
and all that is fighting too i was
trying to talk to my daughter that my
trainer told me something and it it
haunted me he said uh mike i want to
tell you something you got to be careful
how you fight your fights
because by the way you fight your fights
will be the way you live your life
you know what that means all your
mistakes everything you get to make you
successful
and to make you fail in boston will do
the same to you in life
that's deep
it's just it gives you everything our
ego gives us everything but it takes too
much in return
well i always say i like to
keep my boxing personality and keep
who i really am like have them right in
the middle so i don't have to change to
be
i had to change too much to be a certain
type like i'm not going to make myself
be
acceptable for people to like me it's
like i am who i am and each time you ask
me something if it's tomorrow the next
week i got the same answer it's hard
pretending to be somebody who you're not
but this is what you don't understand
this is what you don't understand me you
already change yourself
you know how you change yourself
but changing the world you changed the
world you don't think you did
i definitely did change the world and
i'm still doing that right now you can
always change you're changing constantly
you're changing so fast you can't even
see the change
yeah everything that happened to you is
is supposed to happen to you
and that's what i say that's why i
always look forward i see some of my
fights what was your toughest fight
ah
tommy spike
i don't have to say
my pro debut again hey bill you fought
french on cruise
she is the super middleweight unified
champion right now at 168. uh we fought
a few times in the amateurs
um we fought four times and i beat her
every time in the amateurs we fought my
pro debut and she was just
she's always been stronger than me you
know i kind of came up i was 16 and 17
coming up fighting against women that
was 23 24 to make the olympic team and
she had that women's strength at the
time the time yeah yeah the time i got
the women's strength now but at the time
she had it so when we met
after i won my second olympics franchise
wasn't strong as me but she kind of
had some idea of how i fought and she
had like a fight
with that i remember short she's a good
fighter yeah she's a no back down type
of fighter um
and she really wanted to be me her mom
was watching and her mom passed a week
after this so this was the last fight
that her mom was able to watch her fight
and uh she just really put everything on
the table and i put everything on her
side back too yeah and i came out with
three two yeah and she's a strong big
girl
she's a stronger big girl not afraid
either not afraid of a strong skill
she's waiting to get close to either
clock you understand the assignment yeah
she's strong ooh that's what i'm saying
like this was a four-round war in las
vegas
um on andre wore kovalev yeah undercard
that's when he knocked them out that was
the first fight and we were the first
women to actually fight t-mobile arena
actually me and franton cruz and uh this
fight here was just it was a war and i
was able to come out on top with a
unanimous decision but i really had to
dig deep i love the way you keep your
hands up when you're punching i got to
protect my face a lot of people don't do
it i don't care i don't care
how many 500 300 amateur fights they
don't put their hands up
you know well i grew up in a gym boxing
against guys growing up mike
so the guys used to try to try to hurt
me so i have to learn like that's what
it is offense got to be smarter instead
of being stronger that's the kind of gym
that i grew up in
see i didn't work small when i was um
fighting we work hard we break our knees
we break the bones in our body yes in
training
we want to outwork everybody and we
learned and later in life it's about
working smarter not harder mm-hmm i
learned that so i was about 20 though
yeah you know you want to show the world
this is what i got to save a little form
you know don't give it all to them take
it easy slow smart all the time i
thought i was always in the hospital
hurting my leg hit my hands
fooling around playing in the streets uh
getting street fights got gashes i heard
myself dancing at the club something
that had nothing related to boxing when
i was dancing knock somebody out at the
club i acted
dancing knocked the [ __ ] out oh
[ __ ] come on see some of your
championship fights tell me about the
champions league i've had 12
championship uh
well ten championship fights
which is which is a really good there's
one girl that i thought you for what's
her name she's a good looking girl
christina i mean christina hammer um
that could be her like a mulatto chick
you talking my hannah gabriel yeah and
she just thinks you're tough ass yeah
yeah i whipped her ass and she didn't
think she bad ass yeah and this is me
and christina hammer this was for the
undisputed championship oh at 160.
i took christina hammer for a wild ride
i'll tell you that
and that was probably the easiest fight
in my career and she talked the most
stuff had the best accomplishments
24-0 11 knockouts and i was eight you
know
when we fought this girl from scotland
the ireland or sweden or somewhere
germany jeremy shimona she's a good
fighter though that's how you decide for
who's good and who's great
but this was actually uh
supposed to be my toughest fight in the
pros but um
it wasn't
see everybody think they know what's
right there's no you know listen those
guys those critics those guys that are
picking fights
when human beings are involved
everything anything can happen well i be
telling certain fighters like it's the
media's job to make one fighter be the
monster and make the other fighter be
kind of oh that oh he's not good enough
or she's not good enough to be inside
the ring it's their job to paint the
person to be a monster so christina
hammer was the german monster who was
supposed to come and destroy the
unexperienced
uh girl from flint with the two olympic
gold medals she was supposed to come
beat me up
ripping that right hand to her body
instead of head
right around here you know i gotta get
more better at not head hunting because
my right hand is so fast don't listen no
if you're about to punch if you're a
hard puncher right even the guys are
nowhere punches they hurt you through
the body even though they can't hurt
attention and hurt you because you have
structure but they hurt you to the body
constantly punch to the body body it's
all about the body you know the head
shots are spectacular but um the bodies
take it out of them take that out of the
best of them you find out what they're
made out of if anybody could get hit
with one punching lucky fun boom and get
knocked out when you're getting body
punches you decide not to get up
you're conscious and you make that
decision i'm not getting up yeah cause
because you broke it mentally you broke
them down yeah that's beautiful forget
them head knock i like to break them
down they know they never have a chance
in their life to beat me well that's the
thing about women's boxing though we
only got two minutes to get the job done
two minutes is a lot try holding your
breath for two minutes
no no try talking for two minutes
straight the men have three minutes
if you go to two minutes you could do
three minutes
that's the thing i feel like
you get knocked out in ten seconds and
when they they do it for two rounds you
know why so because there's more
excitement
three rounds might make them struggle it
out but the two rounds you gotta put in
a lot of work in a small increment of
time and that's why it's exciting
yes it makes you work harder and faster
you don't have much time with three
minutes
you can close for a minute right here
you have too much costing for two
minutes
no because because you want to get the
round yeah you want to win the most
closer
oh yes this ideas beat it down huh you
come in i'm pretty mean in there this
mean is good stay smart stay smart
i mean people get knocked out too if
they don't move their head
that's why when i'm in the fight i don't
i'm not mean i'm not i'm not happy i'm
nothing i'm just objective no true
yeah pretty neutral but without with a
mission
once they get you mad they own you
yeah i don't ever fight mad no
oh that hurt
they don't know how much that hurt right
by the ear right that hurts so much you
do oh man
you know no point at that blind
the thing about christina hammer she was
actually uh well once she was
left-handed and she fights her left hand
in front so her left hand was actually
her jab was hard as hell one
but i had figured that out already from
watching a lot of her fight she didn't
think i knew but then again like i think
she she was a pretty good base fighter
but she had no upper body movement as
far as in you know head movement most of
the europeans don't they're straight up
fighters yeah she's kind of more of
moving on her feet than moving her upper
body which i knew was going to be in
close i was going closer with some body
shots right there
that really she felt always come back
with that right left hook yeah right
back like that but bomb always come back
not one punch she could count one count
on one punch two punches mm-hmm
christina herman was a professional
holder also she helped me a lot because
she was fighting look at her shoulders
how big her shoulders are how much did
she weigh
uh this fight was at 160 i think
probably both after we rehydrated
probably waiting now i was 165 i think
she was 168. yeah
she looks big she's smart she's trying
to hit you with somebody punch because
your body punches hurt up you're keeping
the thinking you know you're keeping
them thinking so tell me what's the goal
who is
out there you have a big money fight you
don't fight yeah so
i have a fight october 27 mma for the
pfl
um and then i fight boxing to defend my
titles at 160 in the uk but
after i fight in the uk in december
we're hoping to get
um
savannah marshall she's the only person
to ever beat me in amateurs i was 77 and
one in amateurs savannah marshall had
got a very close decision and i want to
fight her and beat her but that's the
only
um big fight that i have or like or like
if me and franchine was to do another a
rematch in the in the pro but but right
now savannah marshall is who i'm looking
forward to fighting next year do we have
her in there can we see where she fights
are you footed already no i haven't
fought as a pro let's see what this
chick looks like
yeah so they're building savannah
marshall up to be this big old knockout
artist she knocks everybody out she's
tending over like knockouts the uk yeah
but all her opponents have losing
records who she fight against and et
cetera et cetera that's who the next
victim is yeah that's what next victim
is i used to fight hey this is your food
right here champ right here
hey jimmy it's your food right here the
girl she's fighting right now is awful
this is good this is what we're talking
about yeah she's off a weak notice her
opponent has been only been her opponent
for a week
she's showing up to fight her like 15
and 8 or something like that is her
record
she got the little cool moves and [ __ ]
right uh when she feels your jab she's
like [ __ ]
she don't have her hands up now but
she'll have them up then
and i'm saying like the girl she's
fighting to just
i don't know
i don't want to call her a tomato but
wow
if my mentor called you a tomato candy
that would be that's worse than calling
you a [ __ ] that's just some bad stuff
in boxing it's amazing and somebody
listen
the way i grew up my trainer he's from
people in 1908 there's nothing worse
than a tomato can to him if he calls you
a dominican he has no respect for you
your life your mother i don't know why
i don't know what i don't know what the
freeze is because the tomato can won't
give it won't it won't boom you can just
push it you can blow it over it won't
resist nothing just [ __ ] can't
useless mike you see anything that you
um no this is the thing i should be
worried about she's a [ __ ] amateur
but you know she's the top rank amateur
though she ain't no bum amateurs she's
the top average i would i
i would say that when we fought when i
was 17 we were getting ready to go to
the olympics and london was hosting the
olympics so that gave her more of a
favor i'm not mad about the loss because
i won the olympics two times and she was
there if she didn't meddle
yeah like nobody noticed something about
it she's relaxed
she's a relaxed fighter
everybody can be relaxed against bums
oh that's good too she just don't look
like she should be just no she could be
a sparring partner that would be cool
about to be over real soon this is gonna
be really oh this is gonna be really
interesting fight what do you think
about canelo and this guy cap caleb
kaelin kelly plant um [ __ ]
you know what i think that um kayla
possessed the skills to beat canelo i
just don't know if caleb can withstand
the punches
because i think in order to beat canelo
you got to be able to outbox you got to
be able to hurt him you got to be able
to make a respect if you can't hurt him
it's over yeah yeah it's okay he's going
to walk right through you yeah so i
think he was just excused but i don't
know
we was just the power to hurt him or to
withstand his i know he's gonna use
those skills he's gonna miss some
punches he's gonna feel the [ __ ] one
of those punches that he missed and
he'll say [ __ ] i'm gonna get out of this
[ __ ]
he's like
get out of this [ __ ]
tell us more you're in love
yeah right now yes oh [ __ ]
how was that like
you know what i've only been loved twice
and i say the second time was much
better than the first time
and um my boyfriend tony is very
he's different kind of man that i've
ever been with tell me about that
he's uh i'm he's romantic
no no okay no he's not that's not your
kind of guy a romantic guy no i like a
romantic guy but he's just uh
i feel like i can be
nicer with him
like i can be protected by him and i've
always felt like guys that i was with
uh i always had to do like the
protecting of myself the providing for
myself and i feel like he protects me he
can't provide for me
and um he can also handle me also like
he's not softer than me so when i like
if i tell him to shut up or something
he'd like no you shut the [ __ ] up
um
i can't i can't control my wife my wife
won't obey me like that i don't even try
to make her she's just not made like
that you understand that i'm a fighter
but
i love fighting i don't i love boxing or
mma but i don't like to uh fantastic
funny yeah like fight outside the ring i
argue and stuff like that i don't even
like play fighting like people play
hitting me
because i have i think i have an anger
problem or something i like to argue all
year is stimulating
i love to do it
no
very stimulating
especially if we're arguing about an
issue or subject yeah it's pretty good
debating someone debating sheriff but
the argument part is like that's what
they call the baby it's arguing but this
they call it debating i just give him
the win i don't i don't like arguing
sometimes i'm like you know what you got
it it's cool i said what i have to say i
hope we can get past this
and we do
and always love is love yeah
this is your second time in love huh
uh-huh [ __ ]
i remember my first or second kind what
i [ __ ] smuck
[Music]
i'm sponsor for this episode's element
drink mix it's a tasty electrolyte drink
mixed with um everything you need no
sugar nothing artificial no [ __ ] i
i'm an athlete so i depend on my
electrolytes i train hard so i lose a
lot of sodium up to seven grams a day if
you don't get that back i get really
really tired even if you don't train
hard like me everyone still needs
electrolytes you can really get a
headache too or a muscle cramp and if
you don't um hydrate properly oh man
anyone can try to try this risk-free and
money-back guarantee no questions asked
it's already used by many regulars like
nba
nhl
nfl fbi snipers navy seals marines use
element elements some tough [ __ ] anyone
who wants to be a badass all you have to
do is go to
drinkelement.comboxing for a free sample
pack now
oh yeah so you still sparring and
training right now yes i'm i'm actually
right around the corner from here so i'm
in albuquerque new mexico i'm training
at jackson wings gym i train alongside
uh alongside holly holm
you came with holly either by sparred
with her yet yeah
she's going with the best yeah yeah
sparrow uh holly holmes uh arlene blenco
she fights for the fights for bellator
and johnny bonds we do like one-on-one
sessions to where he like shows me some
stuff
and he's a really great fighter i really
wish you the he's the greatest i really
wish you the best man i feel you really
um
you're really i'm driven to do this
yeah i believe that um
i can do anything
put my mind to
and now that i'm 26 i want to retire at
34.35
and i'm hoping that boxing and mma can
make him be a millionaire a household
name and i can kind of step in serena
williams footsteps as far as then like
the branding and stuff so it's it's
coming that's pretty awesome you know
you have to have big goals for yourself
to stay um
determined and i especially i just was
goal orientated my whole life
it's always wanted to accomplish
something
always ego driven had low self-esteem so
it was always ego driven you wouldn't
think you had low self-esteem though
because you gave off that confidence
like you always wanted to kill somebody
but question for you
did you really cried before all your
fights
some of them
why
that's who i am
but i'm saying like why did you cry like
did you cry because you was like so
angry trying to compose yourself or were
you crying because you was like scared
or
a little bit of both
then i'm pretty scared and by being
scared i'm really just something bad to
this guy that his family's not gonna
like
keep him from yeah and then i'm gonna be
really guilty it would feel really bad
at the end
okay yeah that's that's yeah that's how
i fight i only cried before one fight
but it's good
it's um crying is the most
man this is um it's amazing i don't even
know what the core coin is so relieving
yeah if by saying it's a huge relief
even though i hate it but it's sometimes
needed we all have a different
perspective of crying yeah so tell me
man this is um
how many millions of people we got 89
million hundred listen
explain to them
i already know you're the greatest
fighter of your ever but explain this
these people tell them who you are and
how they get in contact with you
i am claress of the gulf shields quote
is g-w-o-a-t because muhammad ali will
always be the goat g-o-a-t so greatest
woman of all time
i'm from flint michigan
i'm a
12-time world champion in boxing
want to know one tko mma with the pfl
i fight again october 27th on espn
i fight december on sky sports
and
you can find me on instagram
twitter facebook at clarissa shields all
with the blue check mark
you're pretty humble
you know what when it like comes to
being humble i always tell people that
i'm humble to god not to man so i feel
like people feel like i can't speak on
how great i am and they say that that
makes me
cocky and not humble but it's like no
god made me great and i'm humbled to god
to know that everything came from him
but i am the greatest
woman fighter to ever walk this earth
period like it'll never be another me i
love the attitude i love the attitude
that's really beautiful
i got the muscle to back it up you know
what i'm saying you gotta put guard in
this too you gotta be divine about this
[ __ ] where you talking about you you
gotta look at yourself i'm the greatest
fighter god ever produced
when you really believe you're the best
in everything that means you're
beautiful and you're beautiful that
means that comes from god so you have to
explain to them that you're down with
god and god is down with you because
this is what he restored upon you yeah
happy favorite i don't know
i just know i know god cares but i just
know that he made me this way to say
what i have to say but it's just it's
all happening this is all love all this
stuff is love
too much and i feel like that's what god
put inside me like to be a boxer and be
a mma fighter sometime i think to myself
i'm like i think i'm kind of crazy but
then again it's like no you just really
love
fighting and that's what god
wants you to do but like to deliver a
message that anybody from anywhere can
make it because i'm from flint i went
through a lot of things growing up and
now i'm sitting here with mike tyson and
he knows i'm the greatest one of all
time yes i do
and just the fact that i that i come
from like humble beginnings and that i
really came from nothing and now
i'm something and i think it wouldn't be
possible without
you know god knowing that this was it
for me but he wants me to tell people
who come from those areas that we can
still make a way for us oh no doubt
about it when you say um you're nothing
you never come from nothing you know all
of that was preparing you for this
all adversity prepare you for this i
guess this big school we live in
this all this world is some big school
we don't even know why we're here we
don't know why we're here till we leave
him
maybe we don't know anything until we
leave probably yeah you know man we
might imagine we never figured this out
even when we die man this is just we
don't figure this out our brain is not
sophisticated enough god didn't make us
sophisticated enough to understand this
do you understand if you didn't know
what you knew now
would you know who you
being like if you didn't know anything
that you know not if you didn't know how
to read you're writing to nobody's name
can you tell somebody who you are
i can't tell somebody who i am i think i
know [ __ ] but i don't really know who am
i
some
[ __ ]
express how i've expressed
who i how i feel maybe but
if all i didn't know all that stuff now
it'd be hard to express who i am yeah i
didn't know that when i think about
myself in that perspective i'm just a
compound of needs and necessities are
never going to get fulfilled
you know and um
that's why i feel like i'm in some big
hole
that really never gets fulfilled
with my greed and all my
you know my ego get involved i want to
suck the world and my gluttonous and
stuff and then i have my wife and my
kids and they bring me back to reality
yeah it's about having somebody to bring
you back it's good that you have your
wife and your kids if i didn't i would
be an animal
and without them i'm nothing nothing i
miss [ __ ]
i'm so very glad that i have them in my
life
you plan on having kids ever
yeah i plan on having my first child at
29 so three more years
that's your plan right that's the plan
hopefully i'm me hopefully i'm married
before then but if not that's still the
plan because i want to
have a kid bounce back fight through
four more years and then
retire what kind of mom you think you'd
be you know what i think i'm gonna be
the mom to be like do not [ __ ] with my
kid
that's the kind of mom i'm gonna be like
my kids gonna be everywhere with me like
you know how beyonce had blue ivy in the
club
my baby's gonna be right there next to
me like we're here if my baby my if my
my baby can't come
i'm not coming it's like my baby's gonna
be with me all the time i'm not gonna be
a stay-at-home mom i'm traveling my kid
gonna be with me that's kind of mom i
see myself being you know what's gonna
happen what you're gonna be you're
hanging a lot of people gonna take your
pictures like they do when they see you
out and just like my chapter my kids
will say oh i'm they don't want that
[ __ ]
our kids don't want that [ __ ] all these
[ __ ] in their face with cameras and
right there oh okay they don't want i
thought my kids don't want that to do
hey look at dad walking down the street
and everybody can't stop touching them
and taking pictures whoa that they get
that um
that stops our relationship from growing
well that's how my family members are
they don't really like that when we go
out places and people are like that
toward me my family members who are
actually grown people and understand
that i'm celebrating like they still
feel like our time together it's our
time together yeah this is what you're
doing that's not normal [ __ ] yeah it's
not really i think you think this is not
normal [ __ ] the [ __ ] that we do
these are the these are the games for
the insane
i know you don't like to look at it but
this is awful you know
we're not crazy because of who we are
we're crazy because what we have to
endure and deal with mm-hmm
you know if you're not crazy in this
world i feel sorry for you
i really do i really do
and everybody understands yeah
you know what i mean
if you're not you ain't gonna be able to
handle the depression if you're not
crazy that's what they say big school
out here no testing us
testing our endurance for life
yeah you know i try to live my life to
my own standards though they all have
like this whole thing of who you should
be how you should be and i'm like look
i'm not i'm not here to live by nobody
else's standards i'm gonna do it make me
happy and just i mean i suck living life
i really suck i'm not good at that at
all what do you mean it's living life
on the rules of life and sometimes i
just do whatever i want to do regardless
of whoever how they are respect that
respect everyone wants that they want to
have the courage to graft for that yeah
that's yeah that's me all day cause
people always say oh women shouldn't
talk trash uh women don't do this women
don't do that and it's like how do you
know what a woman do you're not a woman
you don't you you don't know who i am on
the inside i'm not like
every other woman that you i don't have
to be exactly like them i'm who i am and
people love it some people hate it but
at the end of the day they've been women
millions of years i love it
yeah they found one four million years
old her name is lucy
oh you know and um yeah and who's her
mother who's her grandmother
who's our tim grandmother
what is time time is invisible we don't
even see it huh
yeah time keep going no matter what
yeah
but do you ever think this was that up
to you
like my parents are like
your whole bloodline everything what was
that what led up to me you know what
i do want to know where i'm from that's
the thing that sometime bothers me the
most about being here in america is like
i want to know where was the tribe that
i came from before we got taken over
here
because i thought that has a lot to do
with who i am now as far as like my
attitude towards fighting in just my
internal spirit i think that that has a
lot to do with where i where my original
family came from before i think that's
something i say to myself who put these
thoughts in my mind why do i think like
this only has to come down from my
bloodline has been passed through
somebody yeah i think you know i think
like this i don't like thinking like
this but it is what it is i think
somebody over in africa like my
great-grandparent was like a she-warrior
or something because
what i have inside of me is just
it's just different
and i haven't met another woman like me
yet
you might not meet another man like you
i tell you that all the time like i'm
harding a lot of guys but
i just like you know i just think uh
i just i just accept accept who i am but
i i'm learning myself too and i know
that it's just certain surroundings that
i have to be surrounded with because if
you put me in like an environment where
it's like where they consider the
roughest and the toughest i'm still
going to come out on top i hear that and
i feel like i need to be surrounded
people who knock on me have to be the
roughest or the toughest and i can just
do boxing and stuff
without having to worry about
jail and all that stuff because it's
like i i will always figure out a way to
like
win and i want to just win around
successful people and not like
win at the level of you know street
fighting or
you know having to do stuff that's
you know we we
we reach different levels of love in
life
and one of the levels of compassion
forgiveness
self-forgiveness
yeah self-suffering you know
and once we learn once we learn these um
levels of life
we'd be more secure with ourselves
most of us are people that most most
successful people
have
low self
worth for themselves but they
have more success and i never say how's
that work or not the guy with the lowest
self-esteem is the most successful
person
all the money will run studios but they
don't think well about themselves can do
anything
and i always wondered
why do people think that way they think
that uh
[ __ ] [ __ ] is um
wraps around them and
but they do great things they'll have
self-esteems
i think that that just comes from like
some people upbringing i think that
self-esteem has to be
kind of built into you i know my first
boxing coach was the first person to
tell me that you're the greatest woman
of all time you're the greatest fighter
that was my boxing coach at the age of
13 he told me that so i didn't i didn't
believe it until i was 17 that i was the
greatest woman in fight of all time so
from the age of 11 to like i said 17 he
was always telling me like you the best
can't nobody beat you you know even
after i lost my lost my only fight he
was always telling me you're the
greatest woman fighter of all time i'm
telling you i'm telling you and i just
was like oh no i gotta beat the best
first so you know i gotta but they could
see that before we could they see your
potential experience they've seen it
before they could see before we did yeah
in my box in my first box and sometimes
i wanted to quit you know i wasn't
winning the way i was an amateur i
wanted to quit sometime but i did
how many times are you losing amateurs
quite a few i've been knocked down but i
wasn't a good amateur fighter just as
soon as i turned pro [ __ ] you started
being different
he only lost one time
and i was spawning guys at the gym but
but that one loss really did hunt me for
a couple years though
i had this documentary on netflix it's
called t-rex and every time i watched it
when i lost i would just start boo-hoo
and crying and i did that for like four
years i already had won the olympics and
i still cried every time i seen it and
then after i won my second olympics in
2016
now i can watch it and i don't cry no
more but you know what the loss you know
but it just it hurt me so bad and it
made me just want to i never realized
how much winning meant to me until i
lost when i lost that's when i knew like
you know what
i'm going to train so much harder
because i never want to feel that again
i always tell my daughter that i said
listen you know
and you know you don't have to tell me
but you think about what is it that you
can do
you person what is the person you can do
to make your best tennis player
now you don't got to tell me but just
think be honest with yourself look at
something what is it that you can do to
make yourself a better tennis player and
now that's on you you don't have to tell
me yep that's on you
and you know what that sounds similar to
what my boxing coach talks about when i
lost my first fight
he asked me he said i thought you won
the fight cause he watched it over and
over again he said you won i don't know
how you lost i said well i lost you know
he said but what do you feel like you
could have done better and at the time i
was so frustrated i said i done i did
everything i could
that's what i verbally said to him but
inside of me you know you
did more i was like you know what
my damn legs felt like they was tired
my dang arms felt kind of tired
you know even though i was laying in the
punches i felt like i couldn't get her
from holding me
and when i and when i had that
conversation with myself he like okay so
your legs got tired we're gonna run more
miles oh you feel like your arms got
tired we're gonna punch the bag
and that was something i spoke i said
within myself so the next three months
leading up to the olympics
uh when i lost when i was 17 i had three
months till the olympics it just was
like i was training overtime you know
two miles turned into six
and then uh you know one mile turned
into four and six i'm gonna back turn
into ten and i was just training so hard
so hard so hard
and when i got there to the olympics i
was like
my legs not going to hurt my arm's not
going to hurt i'm in great shape i don't
have no excuses so if i lose in the
olympics i'm like
i can walk away knowing that i gave
everything i had in order to win i did
everything i was supposed to do before i
got here
and so when i got there
people was doubting me but i just was
like
i'm about to show everybody
how i how i get down
that's right it's all a mental game
mental games your body's only purpose is
just to carry your brain
really that's his only prayer it looks
like it has a lot more than that to do
but that's totally perfect
brain gives it the order to move it
doesn't do anything we just hold your
brain yeah
so i'm sorry this is going too
long we have a awesome love fest going
on here about boxing but listen about
boxing about life i love mike tyson so
yeah thank you very much and the same
here i love you as well and
we got to say bye
this is hot boxing with mike tyson the
greatest woman fighter of her generation
cyrissa shields
beautiful having you here thank you yes
thank you so much for having me
appreciate you beautiful
tata
[Music]
you